is burundi's new prime minister this
comes days after president everest
daishimir said some senior individuals
were planning a coup to overthrow his
government
earlier on wednesday parliamentarians
voted to remove the now former prime
minister alain kyonbonyoni
opposition leaders say they hope this
helps ease tensions
all what we want them to do is to
consider
who is able to do what and not who is
more
militantly
partisan than another so
let's say that
the president and his prime minister
and even his political party have now a
big challenge
how do they cope with
the aspirations of the people of puerto
rico
since gaining independence from belgium
in 1962 burundi has witnessed
presidential assassinations ethnic
massacres a long civil war and coups a
failed coup in 2015 plunged the country
into unrest
protests against former leader pierre
korenzisa led to the deaths of more than
one thousand people
[Applause]
president daishime has been in power for
just more than two years his claims of a
planned coup can't be independently
verified but some say it suggests there
could be cracks within the political
system haru mutasa al jazeera